This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。绝对真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养坚韧、健身和构建心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些磨难，你会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即数字TWO。可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他罪有应得。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《回望过去》播客节目中。对1979年来说，那对我是个重大时刻。84年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英国。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回望过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学步》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的专业执业人员交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《艰难学步》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. This decade is filled with a lot of big, vulnerable, sometimes
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一档探讨我们二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化与转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。无论你是新听众还是老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析二十岁的心理。这个十年充满了许多重大的、脆弱的、有时是
unanswerable questions that leave us feeling, if I'm honest, a bit stranded, a bit panicked as well. Questions, of course, to do with the love and friendship in our careers and everything in between, but perhaps one of the biggest ones that we grapple with during our 20s is, what in the world is my calling? What was I put on this earth to do? And is it even something that I'll enjoy? How can I find direction in my life? How can I find my compass when it comes to what jobs I'll do? My five-year plan where I'll live, who I'm becoming, what I actually want from my life. And that is exactly what we are going to discuss today. When we have so many options, but also equally so much confusion about who we want to be, what we want to do,
无法解答的问题，说实话，这些问题让我们感到有点无依无靠，甚至有点恐慌。当然，这些问题与我们二十几岁时的爱情、友情、职业以及介于两者之间的万物息息相关，但也许我们在二十多岁时纠结的最大问题之一是：我这辈子到底的天职是什么？我来到这个世上究竟是为了做什么？这甚至是我会喜欢的事情吗？我该如何在生活中找到方向？当面临我要做什么工作时，我该如何找到指南针？我的五年计划、我将住在哪里、我将成为怎样的人、我对我的人生究竟有什么期望。这正是我们今天要讨论的内容。当我们有这么多的选择，但同时又对我们想成为什么样的人、想做什么事情感到无比困惑时，
what we're even good at. When it feels like this kind of constant battle between passion and practicality, how do we find our calling amongst that? I think this concept of a calling is a beautiful one. It obviously has very spiritual undertones, this kind of sense that each of us is born gifted and each of us has this purpose instilled in us by some higher power. But I think it also reflects our very human need for meaning in our lives. There have been so many articles and studies written on this very idea that without a purpose, we suffer and we don't thrive at the level that we could. And there are some known psychological benefits of having this purpose in life. And let's be clear, that doesn't need to be work. It could be a hobby. It could be a broader goal. It could be family.
我们究竟擅长什么。当感觉这就像是在激情和实用性之间进行着某种持续的斗争时，我们如何在其中找到我们的天职？我认为天职这个概念非常美好。它显然有着非常浓厚的精神内涵，这种感觉就像我们每个人生来就带有天赋，每个人都有某种高等力量赋予我们的使命。但我也认为，这反映了我们人类对生命意义的迫切需求。关于这个理念，已经有无数的文章和研究表明：没有目标，我们就会痛苦，我们就无法达到本应达到的繁荣程度。拥有这种人生目标有一些广为人知的心理益处。需要明确的是，这不一定非得是工作。它可以是一个爱好。它可以是一个更广泛的目标。它可以是家庭。
But having something that you love doing that you care about doing makes us less. vulnerable to boredom makes us feel less stuck or stagnant. There is often this very fundamental sense of our knees that we experience when our attention isn't occupied by external things. And having a so-called calling can mean that we are always striving towards something below the surface and that stops us from being anxious and depressed and feeling a bit cooped up. Another important factor here is that aligning ourselves to a purpose often makes us less self-centered. We feel a part of something bigger. We feel that we are contributing to something outside of ourselves.
但拥有一件你热爱且在乎的事情，会让我们不那么容易感到无聊，让我们感觉不那么被困住或停滞不前。当我们的注意力没有被外界事物占据时，我们经常会体验到这种非常基本的膝跳反射般的感受。而拥有所谓的天职意味着我们总是在为水面之下的某些事物而努力，这能阻止我们感到焦虑、抑郁以及那种被闷坏的感觉。这里另一个重要的因素是，将我们自己与一个目标对齐，通常会让我们变得不那么以自我为中心。我们觉得自己是某个更宏大事物的一部分。我们觉得自己正在为自身之外的某些事物做出贡献。
And that has been shown to actually perhaps make us less focused on our own worries and our own anxieties, perhaps making us better, happier people. Purpose has also been shown to improve our self-esteem. It just makes life a bit more exciting. We all want to feel fulfilled and motivated and like we are contributing something important to the world and those around us. And we are also super lucky these days that we don't just have to see work as a paycheck and a paycheck only. There are just so many opportunities for getting paid to do something that you love or to turn your passion into an income to make it our main focus. But all of that does actually raise the stakes quite a bit, which is why I wanted to mention it first.
事实证明，这实际上可能会让我们不那么关注自己的担忧和焦虑，也许会让我们成为更好、更快乐的人。事实还证明，目标能够提升我们的自尊心。它只是让生活变得更加令人兴奋。我们都希望感到充实、充满动力，觉得我们正在为世界和周围的人做出重要的贡献。而且我们也非常幸运，如今我们不必把工作仅仅看作是一张薪水支票。有太多的机会可以让我们因为做自己喜欢的事而获得报酬，或者把我们的激情转化为收入，使其成为我们关注的焦点。但所有这一切实际上确实把利害关系推高了不少，这就是为什么我想首先提到这一点。
Because I think it's something that we are all pretty much already aware of, especially in our 20s. Something I really hear quite a bit from people is, I know I want to do something meaningful. You know, I don't want to waste my time in a job that I'm really unhappy with. I want to do something that is aligned to a bigger meaning that doesn't help me in discovering what that is. Sometimes the mentality behind needing a calling, wanting a purpose, is what we're going. causes us to get even more stuck. It's the choice overload, the sense that every decision needs to be the right one this early on. It's like, suddenly it's not just about having a roof over our head or a well-paying job, but also having a well-paying job that feeds our soul. Because who wouldn't want that?
因为我认为这基本上是我们所有人都有所觉察的事情，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候。我经常从人们那里听到的一句话是：我知道我想做一些有意义的事情。你知道的，我不想把时间浪费在让我极不快乐的工作上。我想做一些符合更宏大意义的事情，但这并没有帮助我发现那究竟是什么。有时候，对寻找天职、追求目标的执念，正是让我们陷入更深困境的原因。这就是选择过载，是那种觉得在这个年纪每一个决定都必须正确的想法。这就好像，突然之间这不再仅仅是为了有个遮风挡雨的地方或一份高薪工作，而是要有一份能滋养我们灵魂的高薪工作。因为谁会不想要那样呢？
It doesn't necessarily help, though. It just creates a lot more pressure on us and a lot more areas in which we feel the need to be as satisfied as possible. I've also found that sometimes the idea of a singular calling that there is one thing out there that you will do best and the world will applaud you for and nothing else is rather restrictive. We change and so does what gives us meaning, but also your calling can be a number of things. It doesn't have to be something that yeah, you're necessarily getting paid for or that you can make a career out of, but it also doesn't have to be one thing. It can be a combination of many things. It doesn't have to be massive and loud. It can still be small and purposeful. Basically, there is not a single thing in the world each of us is born
不过，这不见得有什么帮助。它只是给我们带来了更多的压力，让我们在更多方面觉得必须尽可能做到完美。我还发现，有时单一的天职的概念——即世界上只有一件事是你做得最好且全世界都会为你喝彩，除此之外别无其他——是相当具有限制性的。我们在变，赋予我们意义的事物也在变，而且你的天职也可以是很多件事情。它不一定非得是你必然能获得报酬或能将其作为职业的事情，而且它也不必是唯一的一件事。它可以是许多事情的结合。它不必宏大而张扬。它依然可以是很小且充满目的性的。基本上，世上并不存在我们每个人生来就被注定
to do. There are many things. There are many things that guide us. And when we get clear on what they are, and when we really drill down into, okay, what are the particulars about the life that I want? We learn so much more about our next steps and about our calling. So strap in, get ready, get excited. We're going to be discussing the Japanese concept of Ikigai, concepts like aptitude and flow, balancing the passion versus the practicality issue, the myth of the dream job, and while you might be able to learn your calling from listening to your body of all things. So much more on top of that. It's going to be a big episode today, guys. Without further ado, let's get into it. One of my favorite concepts to discuss when we're talking about finding our calling is that
要去做的那唯一一件事情。有很多事情。有许多事情在指引着我们。当我们弄清楚它们是什么，当我们真正深入探讨——“好吧，我想要的生活的具体细节是什么？”时，我们会对我们的下一步以及我们的天职有更多了解。所以系好安全带，准备好，兴奋起来吧！我们将讨论日本的“生きがい”（Ikigai）概念，诸如才能和心流之类的概念，平衡激情与实用性的问题，梦想工作的神话，以及为什么你甚至可以通过聆听自己的身体来找到你的天职。除此之外还有更多内容。各位，今天将是内容丰富的一大集。闲话少说，让我们切入正题。当我们讨论寻找天职时，我最喜欢讨论的概念之一就是
Japanese term that I just mentioned, Ikegai. You may have already heard of this. There is a pretty well-known book going around right now of the same name. It has a blue cover, some nice cherry blossoms on the front. But this concept essentially refers to our reason for being or a motivating force, something or someone that gives us a purpose, a feel. feeling of fulfillment and hopefully from that pleasure and enjoyment. It is essentially referring to that really deep sense of satisfaction and accomplishment that we get from doing something we
我刚才提到的那个日本词汇，Ikigai（生きがい）。你可能已经听说过这个词。现在市面上有一本非常知名的同名书籍。它的封面是蓝色的，正面有一些漂亮的樱花。但这个概念本质上指的是我们存在的理由或一种动力，某种或某个人给予我们目标、成就感，并希望从中获得快乐和享受。它本质上是指我们从做自己真正关心且能从中获得成功感的事情中，所获得的那些极其深刻的满足感和成就感。为了找到我们的天职，我们需要被那种感觉所引导。事实上，告诉大家一个有趣的事实，Ikigai这个概念被认为是日本预期寿命如此之高的原因之一，尤其是在
truly care about and which we feel successful in doing. To find our calling, we kind of need to be guided by that feeling. Actually, fun fact for you all, this concept of Ikigai has been suggested as one of the reasons the life expectancy in Japan is so high, especially. in one area in particular called Okinawa, which is not by coincidence, also known as one of the five blue zones, one of the five areas in the world where life expectancy and life satisfaction is significantly higher than anywhere else. And why might that be? Well, we know that living a long, healthy life isn't just about physical wellness, but also about mental health. And having a reason to want to stay healthy, to want to take care of yourself, having community around you,
一个名为冲绳的特定地区，这并非巧合，它也被称为五个“蓝色地带”之一，是世界上预期寿命和生活满意度显著高于其他任何地方的五个地区之一。为什么会这样呢？好吧，我们知道过上长寿、健康的生活不仅关乎身体健康，也关乎心理健康。并且你需要有一个理由去保持健康，去照顾好自己，周围有社区的支持，
of course, but also feeling firm in your reason for being in your drive, in your purpose. And this is Ikigai. Ikeye actually seems to be made up of four distinct components or questions. And answering those questions is what's going to get us a lot closer to knowing our calling. So if you want to know what's going to make you happiest, what you need to do in your life, what you want to do in your life, I guess is a better question. You first need to know, what are you truly good at? What is the secret or not so secret talent or skill that you're always excelling on? You're always getting complimented on that is unique to you. What do you love doing?
当然，还要对你存在的理由、你的驱动力、你的目标感到坚定。这就是Ikigai。Ikigai似乎由四个不同的组成部分或问题组成。回答这些问题将使我们离了解自己的天职更近一步。所以如果你想知道是什么会让你最快乐，你在生活中需要做什么，你想在生活中做什么，我想这是一个更好的问题，你首先需要知道：你真正擅长什么？那个你总能在其中脱颖而出的秘密或半公开的天赋或技能是什么？你总是受到赞美、且独属于你的那个特质是什么？你热爱做什么？
What do you love experiencing? What do you love participating in in general? What does the world need? And what can you get paid for? That is basically the crux of what your calling is. When something fulfills those four things, you've pretty much got a bull's eye. It's a bit more complicated than that. And I really wish that I could show you a picture of this.
你热爱体验什么？你总的来说热爱参与什么？世界需要什么？你能为什么获得报酬？这基本上就是你的天职的核心所在。当某件事满足了这四点时，你基本上就正中红心了。事情比这要稍微复杂一些。我真的很希望能给你们展示一张这方面的图片。
But essentially, there are different levels of fulfillment on your way to finding Ikigai. Like, for example, you know, the dream is to fulfill all four categories. If you love talking to people, if people always say you have such a talent for connecting with others and there is a demand for more therapists, you could get paid to discuss people's problems and, you know, have empathy towards them. you have basically fulfilled all the criteria for Ikegaai. That would be your purpose. You should become a psychologist or a counselor and that would fill all those buckets quite equally.
但本质上，在你寻找Ikigai的道路上有不同层次的满足感。比如，你知道的，梦想是满足所有四个类别。如果你喜欢与人交谈，如果人们总是说你非常有与他人连接的天赋，并且市场对更多治疗师有需求，你可以通过讨论人们的问题并（你知道的）对他们抱有同理心来获得报酬。你基本上就满足了Ikigai的所有标准。这就是你的目标。你应该成为一名心理学家或辅导员，这能相当均衡地满足所有这些需求。
But you can do something that you love that the world needs and not be good and not be paid for that and still feel happy doing that thing on the side whilst working a full-time job. That is what we might call your mission. So volunteering is an example of that. or you can do something you love that you're good at but can never make a career from because the world just might not need it right now. That's your passion like hiking or making, you know, interesting art projects. You still feel fulfilled, but maybe your calling isn't finding a way to do that all the time. Maybe finding a way to get paid for that would mean losing the love for it. And so you
但你可以做一件你热爱、世界需要但你并不擅长且无法从中获得报酬的事，并且在做全职工作的同时，在业余时间做这件事依然会感到快乐。这就是我们所说的你的使命。所以做志愿者就是这样一个例子。或者你可以做一件你热爱且擅长但永远无法将其作为职业的事，因为世界现在可能并不需要它。这就是你的激情，比如远足或制作（你知道的）有趣的艺术项目。你仍然会感到充实，但也许你的天职并不是找到一种全天候做这件事的方法。也许找到一种为之获得报酬的方法意味着失去对它的热爱。所以你
continue to do it as a hobby and, you know, use your job as a way to just, you know, fund that exercise. So I kind of want to spend the rest of this episode talking about each of these components in more detail and how we can kind of fine tune each and truly know what it is that we're great at, what we actually love doing, what the world needs and how to get paid for your dreams. So let's start with kind of working out what you're good at. There are some things that you're just never going to be the best at. Let's be completely upfront. And honestly, that is so liberating when you finally understand that. When you're finally honest with yourself about what you are actually naturally better at,
继续把它当作一种爱好，并且（你知道的）把你的工作当作资助这种活动的途径。所以我接下来想用这集剩下的时间更详细地讨论这些组成部分中的每一个，以及我们如何微调每一个部分，并真正了解我们擅长什么、我们实际上热爱什么、世界需要什么以及如何为你的梦想获得报酬。所以让我们从弄清楚你擅长什么开始。有些事情你永远不可能是做得最好的。让我们完全开诚布公地说。老实说，当你终于明白这一点时，那是极其解脱的。当你终于对自己诚实，承认自己实际上在哪些方面更有天赋时，
it stops you from having to be the person that needs to be the best at everything and crumbles when we're not. It stops you from being stretched too thin or from pouring hours into a skill that, you know, we actually just struggle with, plain and simple. I remember being in high school and I'm sure this is such a common experience, but I was just so terrible at anything mathematical. and I would spend hours on my homework trying to get these theories, you know, route learning them when that didn't work. And as my final exams were approaching and all of these hours were going
它能让你不再需要去做那个在每件事上都必须做到最好、并在做不到时崩溃的人。它能阻止你把自己拉得太满，或者把几个小时的时间倾注在你（你知道的）实际上感到挣扎、简单粗暴的技能上。我还记得在高中时，我确信这是一种非常普遍的体验，但我对任何数学方面的事情都一窍不通。我会花上几个小时做家庭作业，试图理解这些理论，（你知道的）死记硬背，当这不管用时。随着期末考试的临近，所有这些时间都花在了
towards something that I just wasn't improving at, I just honestly gave up. And I spent more time on what I had an aptitude for, which was English and psychology and whatever else I was doing. There is only so much that you can keep pulling the same cart before you ditch it for a lighter one. That's kind of what the gist is here. And this concept of aptitude is important here because it basically says, yes, everybody can learn most things. Everybody could be baseline good at most things if they gave it their everything. But for some people, getting really good at that thing is going to be a lot easier and come to them a lot quicker. There is a reason that LeBron James is a basketball player and James Corden is not.
我根本没有进步的事情上，我老实说选择放弃了。我把更多时间花在我有天赋的学科上，也就是英语、心理学以及我当时在做的其他事情。在你想把这辆破车推下山换上一辆轻便的车之前，你只能拉着同一辆车走那么远。这基本上就是这里的核心要旨。而才能这个概念在这里很重要，因为它基本上说明了：是的，每个人都可以学习大多数事情。如果每个人都付出全部努力，那么在大多数事情上都能达到基础水平的好。但对某些人来说，要把那件事做得非常好会容易得多，也来得更快。勒布朗·詹姆斯是一名篮球运动员而詹姆斯·柯登不是，这都是有原因的；
or that Steve Jobs was, you know, an inventor and not in HR or not a social worker, right? It comes down to aptitude. And I know it's simple, but we all have our own talents. Stop trying to live the life and skills of somebody that you're not. The place I see this a lot is people at university or college who are really struggling and everything seems to just be like 10 times harder for them. They're doing degrees that they, you know, really, don't like because someone has told them to do so or they've told themselves that this is what
或者史蒂夫·乔布斯（你知道的）是一名发明家而不是在人力资源部门或不是一名社会工作者，对吧？这归结于才能。我知道这很简单，但我们都有自己的天赋。别再试图去过不属于你的人生、去掌握不属于你的技能了。我经常看到这种情况的地方是大学里的学生，他们举步维艰，每件事对他们来说似乎都难上十倍。他们正在攻读他们（你知道的）实际上并不喜欢的学位，因为有人告诉他们这么做，或者他们告诉自己这是他们
they should be doing. But it's about having a very, I would say, practical and utilitarian mindset. Where do my natural talents lie such that I'm going to get the most out of an investment in them? So if you aren't quite sure, here's a few questions to seriously consider for just a second. What are people always giving you compliments on? What do your closest friends and family say that you are good at. Is it getting others to open up? Is it being organized? Is it planning the night out?
应该做的事情。但这是关于拥有一种非常（我要说的话）务实和功利的心态。我的天然天赋在哪里，以便我能从对它们的投资中获得最大的回报？所以如果你不是很确定，这里有几个问题需要认真思考一秒钟。人们总是在哪些方面称赞你？你最亲密的朋友和家人说你擅长什么？是让别人敞开心扉吗？是井井有条吗？是策划夜间外出吗？
Is it decorating your space? Putting on an amazing meal. Are children like super receptive to you? I don't know. Maybe you don't know either because you're so caught up in just getting through the day and maybe downplaying your own strengths and being self-deprecating that you've just never actually noticed what you're truly talented at. but your friends and your family, they do notice and they hold the secret here.
是装饰你的空间吗？做出美味的饭菜。孩子们对你超级敏感吗？我不知道。也许你也不知道，因为你太忙于应付日常生活，也许还在贬低自己的优势、自我贬低，以至于你从没真正注意到自己真正有天赋的是什么。但你的朋友和家人，他们注意到了，他们掌握着这里的秘密。
Next, take it all the way back. What was your best subject at school? And here's the thing. It's not just what subject did you get the best grades in, but what subject did you get the best grades in relevant to your effort? It's a little bit more tricky. What achievements are you most proud of and what skills were involved in those achievements? what was what were you required to just be naturally quite good at in order to get to that goal?
接下来，追根溯源。你在学校里最好的科目是什么？关键在这里。不仅是你在哪门学科上取得了最好的成绩，而是相对于你付出的努力，你在哪门学科上取得了最好的成绩？这稍微棘手一点。你对哪些成就最感到自豪？这些成就涉及哪些技能？
Essentially what we are looking for here is your aptitude and your skill set and something that you are naturally just quite good at. Now that isn't always going to be the thing that you enjoy most so here is the tricky part. We have to balance what we are naturally good at with what we actually enjoy and that is the second component of Ikega. of my friends had to do mandatory aptitude testing a few years back for something or other. And after this like three hour long process, she got her results back. And it said actuarial scientist.
为了达到那个目标，你被要求必须具备什么样与生俱来的天赋？本质上，我们在这里寻找的是你的才能和技能组合，以及你自然而然就相当擅长的某样东西。但这并不总是你最享受的事情，所以这里是棘手的部分。我们必须将我们天生擅长的东西与我们真正享受的东西结合起来，这就是Ikigai的第二个组成部分。我的一个朋友几年前因为这样或那样的原因，不得不做强制性的才能测试。经过这个持续了三个小时的过程后，她拿回了精算师的结果。
And for those of us like me who had no idea what that means, it's essentially like applied statistics to determine how likely bad things are going to happen or to perform like a risk assessment. And you know what? She took one long, hard look at that and went in the complete opposite direction. and she is a professional athlete now. She plays football for a living, very different to actuarial science. And I think she's a great example of why aptitude only does take you so far.
对于像我这样不知道那意味着什么的人来说，它本质上就像应用统计学，用来确定坏事发生的可能性有多大或者执行风险评估。你知道吗？她看了很久，仔细端详，然后走向了完全相反的方向。她现在是一名职业运动员。她靠踢足球谋生，这和精算学非常不同。我认为她是一个很好的例子，说明了才能只能带你走到这一步。
We are not bound by what we would be best at if we tried. That is not our only potential. Passion is still a big part of this equation. If you are like me, you might be pretty content doing a lot of things. That's kind of part of the problem. How do we determine what we really love? and what drives us. And the secret is our bodies will tell us. When we feel fulfilled, sustained, passionate, excited, motivated, inspired, all those good feelings. It begins in our brain,
我们不受制于如果我们努力就会表现得最好的事情。那不是我们的全部潜力。激情仍然是这个公式中很大的一部分。如果你像我一样，你可能会对很多事情都感到相当满足。这可以说是问题的一部分。我们如何确定我们真正热爱的是什么？以及是什么在驱动着我们。秘密就是我们的身体会告诉我们。当我们感到充实、持久、充满激情、兴奋、有动力、受到启发、拥有所有这些美好的感觉时。它始于我们的大脑，
but it really manifests in our body and in quite a few physical reactions. A big one is focus. When you really love doing something, it can be almost hard to pull yourself away from it because we are naturally really engaged. We are invested in the task or activity because we are getting enjoyment out of it. Sounds super basic, right? But a high level of focus and flow is what we really need to pay attention to. So a flow state, and we've spoken about this on the podcast before, but it is this mental state, this magical mental state in which we are completely engrossed on a singular task. All of our attention is focused. We can't be just. distracted. It's like being in the zone, but more than that, it's feeling equally fulfilled and
但它真正表现我们的身体中，并伴随着相当多的生理反应。其中很大一个就是专注。当你真正热爱做某件事时，你几乎很难把自己从这件事上拉开，因为我们自然而然地全心投入了。我们投入到任务或活动中，因为我们从中获得了乐趣。听起来超级基础，对吧？但高度的专注和心流状态正是我们真正需要关注的。所以心流状态——我们以前在播客中讨论过，但它是一种心理状态，一种神奇的心理状态，在这种状态下，我们完全沉浸在一项单一的任务中。我们的所有注意力都集中着。我们不会轻易
challenged by what you're doing, energized and buzzing, but also really calm. And the best way to describe it is feeling, I don't know, almost fluid, totally absorbed. There is like an amazing TED talk on this from almost two decades ago. And in it, they kind of explain the way that the psychologists responsible for the concept came to discover it. And it was by watching and observing some of the most talented but also committed and accomplished people in the world. Chess players, surgeons, ballerinas, mountain bike riders, business leaders, all people who had seemingly found their calling and they wanted to know what they had in common. And what they had in common was the way that they all described entering a flow state when
分心。这就像进入状态，但不仅如此，这是一种既感到充实又感到被你所做的事所挑战的状态，充满精力和活力，但同时也非常平静。描述它的最好方式是感觉（我不知道）几乎行云流水、完全投入。近二十年前，有一个关于这个的精彩的TED演讲。在演讲中，他们解释了负责这个概念的心理学家是如何发现它的。他们通过观察世界上最有天赋、最坚定、最有成就的人来做到这一点。棋手、外科医生、芭蕾舞演员、山地自行车手、商业领袖，所有这些似乎都找到了天职的人，他们想知道这些人有什么共同点。而他们的共同点就是，当他们
they did the thing they loved most. It wasn't just discipline or passion or hours and hours of hard work. I'm sure that was part of it, but the sense of trance-like commitment and immersion, when was the last time you felt that way and what were you doing? See, I remember incredibly vividly doing a podcast assignment back at uni for like an international relations class or something or other. And it was like I had entered this altered state. I was so focused and I remember looking up at the clock after editing this, you know,
做自己最热爱的事情时，他们描述自己进入心流状态的方式。这不仅仅是纪律、激情或数不清的苦工。我确信那是其中的一部分，但那种如痴如醉的投入感和沉浸感，你上一次有这种感觉是什么时候？你在做什么？看吧，我非常清晰地记得在大学里为国际关系课或其他什么课程做过一个播客作业。当时的感觉就像我进入了一种改变了的状态。我太专注于此了，我记得在编辑了这个（你知道的）
assignment basically for three hours and I hadn't even checked the time once. Those moments are the ones to really look out for. It took, you know, two more years to really start my show, but I remember that so clearly and I still like can put myself back in that moment of how engaged, but also relaxed I was. And I get to feel that all the time now by doing this. When was the last time that that you felt like that. The other way that our body leads us to our calling is how we feel at the end of the day. You know those days when you go to bed and you just feel truly fulfilled and satisfied and you are genuinely proud of yourself. You feel accomplished. You sleep easy. It's like this warmth. What was it that you did that day that may have contributed to that state? This is what I would call
作业大约三个小时后抬头看钟，我甚至连一次时间都没有看。那些时刻才是真正需要留意的时刻。又过了两年我才真正开始做我的节目，但我依然记得那么清楚，我依然可以让自己回到那种全神贯注但又放松的状态。现在我通过做这个节目，时时刻刻都能感受到那种感觉。你上一次有那种感觉是什么时候？身体引导我们找到天职的另一种方式是我们一整天结束时的感觉。你知道那些日子吗，当你上床睡觉时，你只是觉得真正充实和满足，你由衷地为自己感到骄傲。你觉得自己很有成就感。你安然入睡。这就像是一种温暖。你那天做过的事情中，有什么可能促成了那种状态？这就是我所说的
an involuntary state of mindfulness. You have in some way created the conditions necessary. necessary to be totally present and just happy. And there are so many studies that show us when we practice something we love, our happy hormones, our happy neurotransmitters, they go wild. And those days when your head hits the pillar with a smile, you're experiencing that very biological and psychological reaction, probably closest to inner peace in real time. Listen to your body.
一种非自主的正念状态。你在某种程度上创造了必要的条件。这些条件对于完全身处当下并感到快乐是必不可少的。有这么多的研究向我们表明，当我们练习我们喜爱的事情时，我们的快乐荷尔蒙、我们的快乐神经递质就会狂喜。而当你的头带着微笑挨着枕头时，你正在实时体验那种最接近内心的平静的生物学和心理学反应。聆听你的身体。
It will seriously guide you to your calling. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to discuss. us those final two components of Ikega and the pursuit of purpose in our 20s and beyond. What does the world need and what can we get paid to do? So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers,
它会严肃认真地指引你找到天职。好了，我们要稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我想讨论一下Ikigai最后的那两个组成部分，以及我们在二十多岁及以后对目标的追求。世界需要什么？我们能为什么获得报酬？所以请继续收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养坚韧、健身和构建心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、
researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWO percent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
研究人员、其他健康与健身专家等展开交流，看穿那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》？这就是I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上的“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回望过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英国。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克毒品。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在某天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到了这个时候，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的，我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回望过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学步》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在
experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person
心理健康领域超过十年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，而我们还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们把生活当成了记分牌，生活变成了输赢，史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，你在世上时，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟，绝对是这样。那代表着两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。
Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
加入我——基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《艰难学步》中就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾多次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才破获此案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用来做了什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马林奇尼。我的脑洞大开了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Finding something that we're good at that we actually enjoy is genuinely like hitting the jackpot. It's sad to say, but a lot of people, do go through their life, not having that opportunity and never knowing. So if there is even a
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱之陷阱》播客。找到一件我们擅长且我们真正喜欢的事情，简直就像中头奖一样。遗憾的是，许多人确实
sliver, a small part of you that has found something that drives you, whether it's, I don't know, music, activism, sport, writing, anything, why not bet on it? Why not give it everything and see what happens? Well, that is when the need to balance passion versus practicality comes into things. and the third component that makes up our calling and our Ica guy is what we can get paid to do. It can be really scary to realize that the thing you feel destined to do is super different to the path that you're on, especially when the thing you love may not pay the bills. When I started doing this, I made approximately $0 for the first two years. But does that mean you give up the dream for something that can pay the bills if it means abandoning your purpose or do you find a way to compromise?
度过了一生，却没有获得那个机会，也从未得知。所以，哪怕有一丝一毫、哪怕很小一部分的你找到了某种驱动你的东西，无论是——我不知道——音乐、激进主义、体育、写作还是任何东西，为什么不去赌一把呢？为什么不付出全部并看看会发生什么？好吧，这时，平衡激情与实用性的需求就介入了。构成我们的天职和Ikigai的第三个组成部分是我们能为之获得报酬的事情。意识到你觉得命中注定要做的事情与你目前的道路大相径庭，这可能会非常吓人，尤其是当你热爱的事情可能无法支付账单时。当我开始做这件事时，头两年我的收入大约是0美元。但这是否意味着如果这意味着放弃你的目标，你就要为了能付账单的东西而放弃梦想，或者你找到了妥协的方法？
I think the need to compromise is quite obviously the right choice here. And that's not to discourage people from chasing their dreams because, yes, if you can do it, run with it, give it all you've got. If you can get paid for it, go. But just because you can't make your calling your full-time job doesn't mean that you are neglecting it. I think when it comes to identifying your calling and following it, we need to abandon our all-or-nothing thinking. Either I'm doing what I love and I'm following my dreams or I'm miserable. Maybe that will surprise you to hear me say, but that's reality, isn't it?
我认为需要妥协显然是这里的正确选择。这并不是要阻止人们追逐梦想，因为，是的，如果你能做到，那就放手去干，倾尽所有。如果你能因此获得报酬，那就去吧。但仅仅因为你不能把你的天职当作全职工作，并不意味着你就在忽视它。我认为当谈到识别你的天职并追随它时，我们需要抛弃非黑即白的思维。要么我在做我热爱的事并追随我的梦想，要么我很痛苦。听到我这么说也许会让你感到惊讶，但这就是现实，不是吗？
I think there is this myth around if you do what you love, you'll never work a day in your life. And this endless search for the dream job is sometimes incorrect because firstly, when something becomes your job and your way of making income, I'm telling you now you will lose some of your love for it because it becomes commodified. That is, in every single person I've spoken to is like, I made my passion, my dream job. they have said, you know, you have to love it 200, 300%, because that love will reduce when it starts to be your income. Secondly, sometimes there just isn't a way to make money from what you love, but that doesn't make it not important. And thirdly, sometimes your job can just be your job.
我认为存在着这样一种神话：如果你做你热爱的事，你一辈子都不会觉得在工作。这种对梦想工作的无休止追寻有时是不正确的，因为首先，当某件事成为你的工作和收入来源时，我现在就告诉你，你将会失去对它的一部分热爱，因为它被商品化了。这是我交谈过的每一个人都说过的，我把我的激情变成了梦想工作。他们都说，你知道的，你必须以200%、300%的热度去爱它，因为当它开始成为你的收入来源时，那种爱会减少。其次，有时根本没有办法从你热爱的事物中赚钱，但这并不意味着它不重要。第三，有时你的工作可以仅仅是工作。
And it's, as we said before, just the thing that funds your calling. A calling, you know, it does not need to make money to be sufficiently purposeful. And sometimes in the balance between passion and practicality, practicality, practicality, has to win, like working all those extra shifts to spend three months traveling and volunteering, or working as someone's assistant to get your dream role in five, ten years, paying your dues. Our calling is bigger than the dream job. It can be expressed in so many ways in your afternoons, on your weekends, but also it can be somewhat aligned and not exactly perfect, but 90% there, and the remaining 10% is filled up elsewhere. Again, when we have banned,
并且正如我们之前所说的那样，它只是资助你天职的事情。天职（你知道的）不需要赚钱就能具有充分的使命感。有时在激情与实用性之间的平衡中，实用性必须胜出，比如多上那些额外的班，以便花三个月时间去旅行和做志愿者，或者作为某人的助理工作，在五到十年内获得你梦寐以求的角色，付出你的代价。我们的天职比梦想的工作更宏大。它可以通过无数种方式在你的下午、在你的周末表达出来，但它也可以在某种程度上保持一致，虽然不完全完美，但有90%契合，剩下的10%在其他地方得到填补。同样，当我们抛弃了
in our all or nothing thinking about our calling and needing to find outcalling through work and through a job, we feel a lot less pressure to get it all right out the gate. Sometimes those dreams also take time and we can return to our calling later on. If you want a great example of this, I really recommend this article by Psychology Today called It is Never Too Late to Find Your Calling. In this article, they talk about this concept of a latent calling, something that might remain hidden or under wraps for a few years or a few decades, but never vanishes. It's not expressed openly, but it can continue to inform your sense of identity. And it's not like once you put your calling on the back burner for a little while, for practicality purposes, you've given up forever.
关于天职以及需要通过工作和职位找到天职的非黑即白思维时，我们感到需要一举成功的压力要小得多。有时那些梦想也需要时间，我们可以在稍后重回我们的天职。如果你想要一个很好的例子，我真的推荐《今日心理学》上的一篇文章，名为《找到天职永远不会太迟》。在这篇文章中，他们讨论了潜在天职的概念，这种东西可能会隐藏或保密几年或几十年，但永远不会消失。它没有公开表达，但它可以继续塑造你的身份认同感。这并不是说，一旦你为了实用性的目的将你的天职暂时搁置一会儿，你就永远放弃了。
And they conducted a study last year on this exact idea. And these two researchers, they examined and observed, I think it was about 30, maybe 40 retired individuals. All of them had played musical instruments earlier in life, and they wanted to be musicians, but they'd spent their careers working in other jobs. They were, one of them was a probation officer, an accountant, physician, lawyer, TV producer, and they all spoke about how there had just been practical barriers to pursuing their calling as a career, but a huge number of them went on to revive their calling in retirement. and even more of them kept doing it in their spare time at a consistent, if not a little bit lower level.
他们去年就这个确切的想法进行了一项研究。这两位研究人员检查并观察了大约30名、也许40名退休人员。他们所有人早年都弹过乐器，而且他们曾想成为音乐家，但他们的职业生涯都花在了其他工作上。其中一个是缓刑监督官、会计师、医生、律师、电视制片人，他们都谈到了作为职业追求理想所面临的现实障碍，但其中绝大多数人在退休后重新燃起了对理想的热情，甚至更多的人在闲暇时间以持续的、哪怕稍微低一点的水平继续坚持着。
And this is the crazy finding from this. Compared to the control group, the test group, the group that did not do this, who did not pursue their calling even in their free time, they showed so much greater overall life satisfaction and happiness for finding a way to keep showing up for their calling, even if it wasn't the way that they made money. If you do want to get paid for your calling though, because obviously that would be a fun route to take, think of your dream job at the centre of a web and then list a series of jobs that connect to your dream job in some way.
这就是其中最疯狂的发现。与对照组、测试组以及那些没有这样做、甚至在空闲时间也没有追求理想的人相比，他们表现出了更高水平的生活满意度和幸福感，因为他们找到了坚持追求理想的方法，哪怕这不是他们赚钱的方式。不过，如果你确实想通过理想赚钱，因为这显然是一条有趣的路线，你可以把你的梦想工作想象成一个网络中心，然后列出一系列以某种方式与你的梦想工作相连的工作。
So let me use the example of an author because that's a fun one. You might not be able to write novels full time, but you can go into publishing, which means you'll still get to be in touch with writing or copywriting or ghostwriting. you know, you could be an accountant who clocks off at five and spends three hours each night working on pottery or your debut novel. There are a web of opportunities that exist around one calling. So don't think about it as this singular thing that you'll be happy doing. Think about it as like a big, almost like a big textbook, a big dictionary of different jobs and different professions, some that we might not even know yet, that all can.
所以让我以作家为例，因为这是一个有趣的例子。你可能无法全职写小说，但你可以进入出版业，这意味着你仍然可以接触到写作、文案或代笔。你知道的，你可能是一个下午五点下班，每天晚上花三个小时做陶艺或写处女作小说的会计师。围绕着一个理想，存在着一个机会网络。所以不要把它看作是你做起来会高兴的唯一事情。把它看作是一本大书，几乎就像一本大字典，里面有各种各样的工作和不同的职业，有些甚至是我们现在还不知道的，它们都可以
connect back to the thing that drives you. Finally, let's turn to the most selfless part of what our calling should contain, and that is what is it that the world needs. Maybe instead of focusing on how your calling could make you money, which is a valid concern, of course, you think about the value of your calling as being what it provides to others. This brings me to another huge myth around finding our calling is that our calling needs to be impressive and have a love.
与驱动你的事物联系起来。最后，让我们转向我们理想中应该包含的最无私的部分，那就是世界需要什么。也许与其关注你的理想如何为你赚钱（当然这是一个合理的担忧），不如把你的理想的价值看作是它为他人提供的东西。这就引出了关于寻找理想的另一个巨大神话，那就是我们的理想需要令人印象深刻并具有巨大的
impact it needs to elevate us so that the whole world can see it. That is a really nice vision, but actually I think our calling can be a lot more simpler. It's what we can do for our friends, our family, our community, those who need us. And it comes back to what we spoke about at the very beginning, our aptitude. What can we give the world that others maybe can't? What are the talents that we possess that are rare and unique and focus on the small impact that you can make with that. I want to talk about an idea here you've probably heard about before called the butterfly effect. So the butterfly effect is not a psychological theory, but actually a mathematical one. And the premise is small things in one space can have a big impact. A butterfly, you know,
影响力，它需要提升我们，让全世界都能看到。这是一个非常美好的愿景，但实际上我认为我们的理想可以更简单一些。它是我们能为朋友、家人、社区、那些需要我们的人做的事情。这又回到了我们在最开始时谈到的能力。我们能为世界提供什么可能是别人做不到的？我们拥有哪些罕见而独特的才能，并专注于你用它所能产生的小小影响。我想在这里谈一个你以前可能听说过的概念，叫做蝴蝶效应。所以蝴蝶效应不是一个心理学理论，而是一个数学理论。其前提是空间中的小事物可以产生巨大的影响。你知道，一只蝴蝶
flapping its wings in Sydney can push the air just enough that it gets swept up, made bigger and bigger and creates a cyclone in Turkey. Your calling, as small as you may practice it, can have a butterfly effect and can be what the world needs or what just one person needs in a moment. You making art and poetry and cool stuff and posting it on social media could inspire someone else to be creative.
在悉尼扇动翅膀，可以推动空气，使其汇聚起来，变得越来越大，并在土耳其制造一场气旋。你的理想，无论你以多么小的规模去践行它，都可以产生蝴蝶效应，并成为世界在某一时刻所需要的东西，或者仅仅是一个人所需要的东西。你创作艺术、诗歌、很酷的东西并将其发布到社交媒体上，可以激励其他人变得更有创造力。
You talking to your friends about social justice could help educate them enough to speak out themselves, creating a butterfly effect in their own circles or their workplace. You volunteering for just two hours a week could be the thing that makes someone feel seen or feel supported. I think part of why we find purpose is something
你和朋友谈论社会正义，可以帮助他们受教育到足以自己发声的程度，从而在他们自己的圈子或工作场所产生蝴蝶效应。你每周仅做两小时的志愿者，就可能是让某人感到被看见或被支持的事情。我认为我们寻找目标的一部分原因在于
is when we see it expanding beyond us. Yes, it makes us happy and fulfilled and we may even enter a flow state and be good at it, but it's when it's shared and when we see it making some small difference or an impact that we truly feel like we have a mission. as localized or small as that may be.
当我们看到它超越了我们自身并不断扩展时。是的，这让我们感到快乐和满足，我们甚至可能进入心流状态并擅长它，但只有当它被分享，当我们看到它产生了一些微小的差异或影响时，我们才真正觉得自己有了一个使命，无论它是多么的本土化或微小。
Now, I want to give you three final exercises to finish off our episode. These exercises are basically designed to reveal what you may already know to be true about your purpose, but you've probably forgotten. There are some exercises that you might typically encounter in like organizational psychology or when you go see like a career therapist. So firstly, think about what life, what kind of life may be possible for you, by looking at those that you admire the most. Those people who you see as heroes or who you idolize,
现在，我想给你三个最后的练习来结束我们的这一集。这些练习基本上旨在揭示你可能已经知道的关于你的人生目标的真相，但你可能已经忘记了。这些练习是你通常在组织心理学中或者当你去看职业治疗师时可能会遇到的那种。首先，通过观察那些你最崇拜的人，思考对你来说什么样的人生、什么样的人生活可能是可能的。那些你视为英雄或偶像的人，
what about their life and their work is so alluring to you? What does it say about your own values? Sometimes the people we admire the most in life give us a clue as to how we might want to contribute to a better word ourselves or what our kind of greater goals or desires are. And it's a form of positive upward comparison that is really powerful, whereby their existence doesn't make us feel inferior, it actually makes us feel quite inspired because it proves to us that what we dream of, the life that we want for ourselves,
他们生活和工作中的什么对你来说如此诱人？它说明了你自己的价值观是什么？有时我们在生活中最崇拜的人会给我们提供线索，让我们知道我们可能想如何为建设一个更美好的世界做出贡献，或者我们更伟大的目标或愿望是什么。这是一种非常强大的积极向上比较的形式，在这种比较中，他们的存在并没有让我们感到自卑，反而让我们感到非常鼓舞，因为它向我们证明了我们所梦想的、我们为自己想要的生活、
the calling that we envision is possible. This works best when you think about people around you who you admire. Sometimes those larger-than-life examples can feel very far off and untouchable, but seeing people in our own lives who really inspire us makes us think about our own mission. And we look at them and we think, okay, really, really, I'm not jealous, I'm not envious, but I really admire that part of their life. What does that say about what I might be lacking in mine? And not can I, not like how can I be more like them, how can I copy them, but how can I really emulate what they're bringing to their life to give them this reality?
我们所设想的理想是可能的。当你想到周围你崇拜的人时，这种方法效果最好。有时那些比生活本身更宏大的例子会让人觉得非常遥远和不可触及，但看到我们自己生活中真正激励我们的人会让我们思考我们自己的使命。我们看着他们，心想，好吧，真的，真的，我不是嫉妒，我不是羡慕，但我真的很欣赏他们生活的那一部分。这说明了我的生活中可能缺少什么？并不是我能不能，不是像我怎样才能更像他们，我怎样才能复制他们，而是我怎样才能真正效仿他们带给自己生活的、给他们带来这种现实的东西？
Secondly, let's talk about this exercise that's called the Good Purpose Challenge. And this originated from the University of California in Berkeley. In this exercise, you are asked to imagine yourself at 40 years old as if everything has gone exactly as you would have wanted it. With that image in mind, really think every single thing you try, you immediately succeed at. You never fail at any of your risks. Everything works out for you. And I want you to answer these three questions. What are you doing?
其次，让我们来谈谈这个名为“美好目标挑战”的练习。这起源于加州大学伯克利分校。在这个练习中，你被要求想象自己40岁时的情景，就好像一切都完全按照你想要的方式发展了。带着这个画面，好好想想你尝试的每一件事，你都会立即成功。你在任何风险中都从未失败。一切对你来说都很顺利。我想让你回答这三个问题。你在做什么？
What is actually important to you at this time in your life in 40 years? What do you really care about? And what do you spend your time on and why? This exercise is really valuable because it zooms you out. It stops you worrying about what you're doing right now and needing everything to be perfect in the moment. And it stops us worrying about all the sacrifices and how confused we are. And it puts us some 40 years in the future and lets us work backwards.
在40岁时你人生的这个阶段，什么对你来说才是真正重要的？你真正关心的是什么？你把时间花在什么上面，为什么？这个练习非常有价值，因为它把你的视线拉远了。它让你不再担心你现在正在做什么，不再需要当下的一切都完美无缺。它让我们不再担心所有的牺牲以及我们是多么的困惑，它把我们置于未来40年的时间里，让我们倒推回来。
It removes some of the practicality anxieties that we have about the future that we encounter so much in our 20s. Because what this hypothetical, what this exercise is asking you to do is to really imagine, like it's all worked out. We are secure. We are stable in this situation. And when that is taking care of, where does your mind turn to? It's kind of like that question of what would you do as money is no object. but a little bit different and I think a little bit more detailed. Finally, I want to give you five final questions for getting through this maze.
它消除了一些我们对未来的现实焦虑，而我们在20岁时经常遇到这种焦虑。因为这个假设，这个练习要求你真正去想象，就像一切都解决了。我们在这种情况下是安全的。我们在这种情况下是稳定的。当这一切都被照顾到时，你的思想会转向哪里？这有点像那个问题，如果不考虑金钱，你会做什么？但有点不同，我认为更详细一些。最后，我想给你五个最后的问题来帮助你穿过这个迷宫。
If you are someone who really benefits from like writing things down, these are amazing journal prompts as well for doing like the intense deep work to find your calling. And here's the thing. I'm going to make this final argument. Very rarely do we actually do this. very rarely in our lives are we, do we step out of that passive role and actually have a look around and be intentional and not just make a plan for a future, but make a vision for the future, and do some of that self-reflection and some of that self-focus that, you know, might feel like a bit boring right now, might feel a bit tedious, but which I would say the majority of people
如果你是一个真正从写下事情中受益的人，这些也是非常棒的日记提示，可以用来做深入的深度工作来寻找你的理想。事情是这样的。我要提出这最后一个论点。我们在生活中很少真正这样做。在我们的生活中，我们很少走出那个被动角色，真正环顾四周，带着意图行事，不仅为未来制定计划，而且为未来制定愿景，并进行一些自我反思和自我关注，你懂的，现在可能感觉有点无聊，可能感觉有点乏味，但我可以说绝大多数人
never get the opportunity to do. And so it's not that there is this competition, but you really are putting yourself ahead in terms of your self-awareness, your self-knowledge. And when it comes to making decisions, when it comes to facing crossroads, you are better equipped to do what you think is right and to do the best thing for your future. These are the five questions that I think are important for getting us to that point of clarity. If you could not fail, what would you do? A very basic one, an important one though, really think about it.
永远没有机会这样做。所以这并不是说存在这种竞争，但你在自我意识、自我知识方面确实让自己处于领先地位。当需要做出决定时，当需要面对十字路口时，你更有能力去做你认为正确的事情，并为你的未来做最好的事情。我认为这五个问题对于让我们达到那种清晰的境界非常重要。如果你不会失败，你会做什么？一个非常基础的问题，但也是一个重要的问题，好好想想。
If you had to teach someone something about a topic or a skill, what would you choose and what would you feel most passionately about? In which situations do you feel most empowered and excited in? If you could sum up your ideal work in five descriptive words, what would you choose? Are you living your life in a way that if your calling was to come to you tomorrow, would you be able to follow it? would you have the belief in yourself to be able to do it? I think that last question really lets us reflect on whether we actually are open to the things that might present themselves to us and that we might not know of yet that may be a surprise, but actually end up being our destiny in a way.
如果你必须教给别人关于某个主题或技能的知识，你会选择什么，你对此会感到最热情的是什么？在哪些情况下你感觉自己被赋予了最多的权力和兴奋？如果你能用五个描述性词汇概括你理想中的工作，你会选择什么？你现在的生活方式是这样的吗：如果你的理想明天降临，你能够追随它吗？你会有相信自己能够做到的信念吗？我认为最后一个问题真的让我们反思，我们是否真的对可能向我们呈现的事物持开放态度，而这些事物可能是我们还不知道的、可能会带来惊喜的，但实际上最终在某种程度上成为我们的命运。
Are you actually letting yourself being inspired? Or are you flexible enough to fit into your dream life? or are you continuing to again pull a heavy cart that might not be for you? I want to say if you haven't found your calling yet, it's actually totally okay. And, you know, I've made this whole episode being like, this is your instruction manual to doing it. But you actually do have time. You do have time to experiment. You do have time to just exist without feeling like you need to be doing something that is bigger and greater and higher than you.
你真的在让自己受到启发吗？或者你是否足够灵活，能够融入你的梦想生活？还是你继续拉着一辆可能不适合你的沉重手推车？我想说的是，如果你还没有找到你的理想，其实完全没关系。而且，你知道的，我制作整集的节目就像是说，这是你这样做的说明手册。但你其实还有时间。你确实有时间去尝试。你确实有时间去单纯地生存，而不觉得你需要去做一些比你更大、更伟大、更高尚的事情。
I will say I talk to so many people in their 20s. I am someone in their 20s, my friends of people in their 20s. I feel like only the small minority of us have any clue about what we're doing. And it's likely that in the next 20 years that will change again. So if you're feeling lost, if you're feeling a bit confused, chaotic, panicked, panicked about not knowing what you want to do with your life, that's actually a really normal experience and maybe everything you're experiencing is actually preparing you to be ready for what is coming. Maybe your calling doesn't exist yet and maybe you need to explore first. Maybe your calling is bigger, maybe smaller than you've been thinking.
我得说，我和很多20多岁的人交谈过。我是一个20多岁的人，我的朋友也是20多岁的人。我觉得只有我们中的一小部分人对自己在做什么有一点线索。而且很可能在接下来的20年里情况又会发生变化。所以如果你感到迷失，如果你感到有点困惑、混乱、恐慌，对不知道自己想用生命做什么感到恐慌，这其实是一个非常正常的经历，也许你正在经历的一切实际上正在让你为即将到来的一切做好准备。也许你的理想还不存在，也许你需要先去探索。也许你的理想比你想象的更大，也许比你想象的更小。
That is where I think a whole part of this is actually just being open to possibility and opening yourself up to things that you may not have expected, not feeling like, Like there was one thing that you needed to do. You had a blueprint, you had a plan, and that's what you need to follow. Let yourself be changed. Let yourself change. Let yourself adapt to these new things that you're discovering about yourself. And it will work out, I promise you.
这就是我认为其中很大一部分实际上只是对可能性持开放态度，让自己对可能没有预料到的事物敞开心扉，不要觉得，好像有一件你需要做的事情。你有一个蓝图，你有一个计划，这就是你需要遵循的。让自己改变。让自己改变。让自己适应你正在发现的关于自己的这些新事物。一切都会好起来的，我向你保证。
And if it doesn't work out, it doesn't mean that you're going to be unhappy. You know, a calling does seem to have this very like golden feel about it. It does seem to be quite mythical and spiritual. But there are so many people who would say, I didn't find a calling, but I found a good life. and that meant a lot to me as well. So regardless of that, I just hope that you did learn something. I hope that this has been a time for you to just think about yourself and spend some time in your thoughts, you know, working through the maze.
如果事情没有成功，并不意味着你会不高兴。你知道，一个理想似乎确实有一种非常金色的光芒。它似乎确实非常神话和精神化。但有很多人会说，我没有找到理想，但我找到了美好的生活，这对我也意味着很多。因此，不管怎样，我只希望你确实学到了一些东西。我希望这段时间能让你只考虑自己，并在你的思绪中度过一些时间，你知道的，穿过迷宫。
I hope that you enjoyed this episode. And if you did, share it with somebody who you think might also gain something from it. Follow us on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you are listening right now, make sure that you leave a five-star review wherever you are listening right now. It helps the show to grow and meet new people. And if you want to follow up to this episode, if there is something that I spoke about in here that you're like, maybe I want to hear more about that or just some other 20-something experience that you want to know the psychology behind, I would love to hear from you.
我希望你喜欢这一集。如果你喜欢，请把它分享给你认为也会从中受益的人。在Spotify、Apple Podcasts上关注我们，无论你现在在哪里收听，请确保你在无论哪里收听时都留下五星好评。它有助于节目的成长并结识新朋友。如果你想跟进这一集，如果我在里面讲过的一些事情让你觉得，也许我想听到更多关于它的信息，或者只是你想了解其背后的心理学的其他20多岁的经历，我很希望能听到你的声音。
And until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle to yourself. And we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
直到下半场，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会谈话。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了心理坚韧度、健康和在奇异的现代世界中建立复原力的科学
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听2%节目。也就是IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的数字2%。当一群女性发现
they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在Iheart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。在《回顾一个播客》中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重要时刻。84对我来说很大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集中，我们选择一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同仁和最喜欢的作家一起度过难关的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is a about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人克尔·加姆斯主持的《艰难学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行这些对话的。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHard电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。这是一个IHart播客，保证是人类制作的。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。